j'aime ce que vous pensez mal à plus
tard ballet comme toutes les autres
la vôtre la mienne elle profite d'un
appareil ont compilé un peu les livrets
a et moi que patrick tillie vaincu
d'afrique la formule est violente et
reflète le ras-le-bol de deux
quinquagénaires confronté au refus de
devoir conjugal de la femme est comme
une honte et la force
même combat pour gérard lanvin deux
chauffeurs et qui sont la vie le patron
qui sont ici un lot de complices dans la
grande tradition de la comédie française
qu'est ce qu'on pourrait le retrouver
pour lui rendre un peu plus sympathique
vos personnages rien il ne faut pas les
rendre plus sympathique ça fonctionne
comme ça parce que en fait ce sont des
jeunes sympathiques sont des hommes
aimant c'est chic ce trafic
c'est par amour quelque part c'est parce
qu'ils sont désespérés
et quand l'animateur sa part comme une
espèce de jeu et ça devient
catastrophique et bien la même que
j'essaie de me laver égoutter de leurs
fans elle remplit et le sacré fait l'ena
n'est pas épargné mon mari va compliquer
ma carte de crédit parce qu'il trouve
qu'on n'est pas l'amour assez souvent
très très original c'est une femme qui
écrit ça laisse pantois fut misogyne
sais pas ce que je veux dire c'est que
ça ne rejoint pas du tout le point de
vue des hommes on est on est bien chargé
de dents et les femmes aussi mais je
dirais qu'elle a une vision très très
l'acide très mordante
c'est très choquant que je me demandais
s'il leur était visité ce choix ce jeu
de massacre selon eric la place que peut
prendre l'argent dans le couple mais
aussi la lettre q l'érosion des
sentiments c'est une femme très loin de
leurs personnages feront leur salaire
soit prédécesseur surtout pas adopté la
technique de mon personnage bien écouté
d'être le moins souvent possible
ensemble